okay so welcome to this public um dis
panel discussion on nuclear fusion for
decarbonized future this event is
co-organized by uh the falling walls
foundation and the embassy of Italy in
Berlin both organizers uh believe that
open access to scientific research and
also public engagement in this
scientific debate are extraordinary
opportunities for so societal growth and
it's a big challenge that you know our
humanity is is facing uh can only be
approached by multinational
collaborative
efforts so now the connection between
energy production and climate um is
nowadays clearly clearly recognized and
uh these two problems go hand inand and
they are you know of planetary
importance and therefore we need uh you
know a global
approach uh and uh and Global Solutions
so we know that nuclear fusion May
provide together with uh other clean
energy uh sources a long-term uh
solution for this urgent problem and
this is what we're here to discuss today
with our five eminent uh speakers and uh
we're very grateful that they came all
the way here uh they are not only you
know uh experts in the field but they're
also leading uh some of the major uh
nuclear uh Fusion uh centers in the
world and they come from three
continents so I will start by
introducing them in the order in which
they will speak first of all we have
here on my left Petro barabasi who is
the director general of erer in K
Kardash France then we have Mas masaya
hanada the director general of Naka
Fusion Institute in
Japan we then have Steven cowy director
uh of Princeton plasma physics lab in
the
US pioro sonato who is the president of
rfx Consortium in Padova Italy and
finally harmit zom who is the director
at MPI Max plank Institute of plasma
physics in
Munich
now so before uh diving into this panel
discussion I would like to leave the
word to to um uh the deputy head of
mission of the Italian Embassy in Berlin
uh Luigi esto who will say a few words
of welcome thank you very much professor
pascarelli and uh thank you everybody
for being here I'm very happy to
participate with very interesting and
important event we will enter into we
will know uh all about the
nuclear fusion is a very important
subject especially because nuclear
fusion
will be pivotal in the future
for the clean energy our next generation
will uh will need why we are uh
sustaining and co-organizing this event
because of course as Italian Embassy we
strongly believe in the international
cooperation is of Paramount importance
in the scientific research but in all
our other aspects of our uh life uh the
international cooperation of course
starting with the one between Italy uh
and Germany Italy and Germany cooperate
in very different fields in the
scientific uh research also contributing
together to The Ether project but also
with their own National ER project the U
presence of the Italian scientific
research in Germany is very significant
we have more than 300 professors
University professors of Italian origin
Italian background and more than 4,000
researchers of Italian background
working in Germany so is a very alive a
very um important uh interaction that we
have but of course today we will also
hear experiences and operation with
Japan and with United States so will be
this will be very very interesting and
important it is important the
cooperation between Academia and
Industry especially for uh manufacturing
countries like Germany and Italy are um
so the finding Innovative solution that
just through an academic research uh can
go ahead is of Paramount importance also
for the economic growth and of course it
is also important the engagement in the
scientific research as an element of H
contribution to uh uh the social uh
growth the social awareness Professor
pascarelli also cited the subject the
theme of uh climate change is something
that is we are confronted all together
and we have to find solution so there is
also a strong social
and human I would say responsibility in
identifying new solution for the future
and of course we have to to to look uh
primarily towards scientific research as
a guide to find this solution so would
like to thank you so much for the uh
your presence and enjoy this very
interesting Journey uh into the nuclear
fusion thank you so
[Applause]
much thank you very much uh Dr esto so
now uh I'll say a few uh let's say
technical uh details so we were we're
going to try and keep the timing so each
speaker has 10 minutes and I will you
know make a sign after seven minutes so
you know that the time is coming to the
end uh we want to keep at least 30
minutes at the end for questions and
answers uh also when you ask a question
please use the microphone you will be
given a microphone because this event is
streamed and otherwise nobody will hear
what you say except for the people here
in the room uh so this is a very diverse
audience I see there's kids so not all
of you are experts in nuclear fusion so
we decided to start with an opening
video that tells you about you know the
physics of fusion how does it work uh
what are the technological challenges uh
that we are uh going into and that we
have to solve and uh uh so now we can uh
start with this opening
[Music]
[Applause]
videoen is isotopes are tum with one
proton and one Neutron and titium with
one proton and two neutrons so they
collide with a very high energy at
temperature around 150 million de which
is 10 times higher temperature than in
the center of the Sun and they can fuse
so we have helium element and we have
one Neutron so this is the most
important part of the reaction because
Neutron takes
80% of all energy of the fusion
[Music]
[Applause]
reaction over the development of the
past decades two concepts have basically
survived this dvinis process and that's
the Tokamak and the accelerator and both
have in common that the magnetic field
is ring shaped but there's there are
subtle differences between Tokamak and
stellarator not just the name a toac is
a Russian word and essentially it just
means a donut that is not exactly what
that is not what Russ Russian for donut
is but toak is essentially a donut
shaped chamber so toak is a Russian
acronym and means just in Russian
language um toal chamber and magnets so
it's very very straightforward and so it
has nothing to do with a Tomah HW never
never confuse
[Music]
that
it turns out we need strong magnetic
fields so we actually need uh two types
of magnetic field uh the first one
happens in what we call the toroidal
direction this is following the shape of
the Taurus around but that wouldn't be
quite enough to keep it completely
confined so what we do is we actually
want a magnetic field as well in what we
call the poloidal direction and that
sort of introduces a
[Music]
twist
first thing you do is you evacuate that
vacuum vessel you pump it and you get
rid of all the gas in it then we
starting to charge our magnetic system
around the vacuum chamber you put a tiny
amount about a postage stamp worth of
fuel you inject that in multiple areas
and then you switch on a solenoid which
is in the middle of the of the toac and
this by the magic of physics create an
electric field in this IND donut the
hydrogen gas detarium and tritium start
swirling around inside the toac then our
first heating system kicks on and it
zaps this gas into a plasma and the
whole thing starts swirling around the
toac so then you use the the the RF
heating systems and another heating
system called neutral beam you fire in
beams of particles and that gets you
from the sort of one to 10 million de up
to the 100 150 million de and then the
process of Fusion starts the particle
can knock each other sufficiently fast
so they fuse and then they produce
energy then you have lit a sun inside
your
[Music]
[Applause]
cage okay so uh now that everybody uh is
on the same page I think we are ready to
start
much so uh we now start with Petro
barabasi our first Speaker director
general of erer go ahead petro and this
is thank you so much so I've seen
already some nice images uh from the
previous video that we are indicating
how ether looks like with some
explanation so I will naturally not
speak about the process of fusion I will
just tell you a few words and show you
some images about um where the eer
project stands ether project is really
an international
project uh the i in ether stands for
international it is international to the
seventh power because we have seven uh
members that participate more than half
of the um uh world population uh and I
think it's part of the objective of this
beautiful scientific project is also to
show um that uh world population can uh
work in peace
for science for a common
goal I think we should be proud of
that um so theer project is being built
now in kadash it has been going on for
quite some time and U I will show you
some
images is it this one yes uh the mission
of ether is uh to reproduce as was said
the nuclear fusion reaction with theum
and tritium I should say that it's not
exactly what goes on the sun the sun has
a different type of reaction this is a
proton proton reaction which is a
reactivity which is significantly lower
uh it wouldn't really be very practical
to have proton proton reaction on Earth
so we use theum and Trum because the
power density is sufficiently high
believe it or not in the Sun the power
density is in fact closer to the one
that we have in the center of our body
it gets really hot because it's so big
but it wouldn't be very practical on
earth besides it would be very
complicated to reproduce
so the objective is to get the
thermonuclear plasma built by Trum and
etherium going it will run for
sufficiently long durations not really
in steady state but for several minutes
which is what we think will be enough to
demonstrate uh the technological
feasibility of course the scientific
feasibility but the technological
feasibility is what is really driven the
design of eer in order to have then a
future a potential future in energy
production so we are now uh pretty well
ahead with the construction of most of
the Civil Works and the support systems
and you see an over an overview of the
overall ether site in the south of
France I will not go through each system
we don't have the time to do that but of
course you will be able to see a lot of
information in the website and there
plenty of information available in the
web I will just show you a few Parts
this is a a view of the Assembly Hall
where you see segments of the vacuum
vessel and uh and coils that are
preassembled uh after pre-assembly they
will be lowered in the pit in the big
cylindrical cryostat uh that is see
nearby the assembly hole but this is
pretty much what you would see now in
the assembly all of
eer there is a movie here which I would
like like to ask somebody to start where
I would try to um describe as we fly
it's it's made with a with a drone we
start again with the assembly hole and
this huge TF coils the d-shaped coils
that create the toroidal component of
the magnetic field that a colleague
explained before inside the vacuum
chamber this is again it's a slice of
the big vacuum chamber and this is a
piece of the Central soleno Central
soleno is the magnet that gets the
plasma current started there is a stuck
up of this Central solenoid all magnets
are
superconducting and superconducting
requires a temperature of minus 269
Kelvin so we have 150 million degrees in
the plasma but neighboring we have
magnets that need to be close to 4
Kelvin so and this is the cryoplant this
is the system that allows to cool the
magnet to that temperature it provides
about 75 kilowatt of cooling power at 4
Kelvin but we also have a heat rejection
system because the nuclear reaction
would produce about 500 megawatt of
fusion power and so there is a system
which is designed to absorb this power
and reject it into the atmosphere we
will not produce electricity in eer
because it's an experiment but still we
will have to exhaust this power this is
a factory in data site to fabricate the
biggest magnets which has are the ring
coils that produce the poloidal
field they cannot be transported they
are just too big so they had to be
fabricated exactly on the eer side which
was in itself a big challenge all of
them again are going to be uh super
conducting sometimes in the close
future we move ahead and we'll show you
add additional parts of the site here
you will see here how construction is
ongoing for the fabrication of the
building that will host the neutral beam
injection system this is going on
exactly now neutral beam that we will
hear a few words later from Pier Georgio
will contribute to the heating of the
plasma and now just dive in and you will
see as we enter the Tokamak hole and the
pit and in the pit you see there one
sector already mounted and I should say
now that we had to pull this sector out
because we had to repair it I will spend
a few words about that because not
everything went as planed and in big
projects I think sometimes go
astray I think we shouldn't be say uh
too concerned about that because this is
normal I work myself in other projects
and I never had the project that
everything was smooth so we just have to
get on with the fixing the problem I
will tell you about that because I think
it's important to be totally transparent
also about problems also make sure that
others will not make the same mistake so
this again it's an image of the TF coil
one TF coil each one weighs about 400
tons and just to give you the scale is
about 17 M
High and the cryoplant I said before 75
Kelvin 75 kilowatt at 4 Kelvin doesn't
look a lot but bear in mind that to
extract energy at that temperature and
exhaust it in the atmospheric say at
room temperature it takes about 1,000
times more energy so the cry plant is is
say in the range of 100 megaw it says
for the
compressors and we had some troubles now
to fix one in the vacuum vessel vacuum
vessel had some non-conformities we are
fixing that is not big big trouble and
we also have found some last year some
leaks in some helium pipes that cover
the thermal Shield so bear in mind that
vacuum vessel operates at about 200
Centigrade and we have also thermal
Shield next to the magnet because the
magnet has to be at 4 Kelvin so we need
a special Shield that has to be cooled
at 80 Kelvin and so we had some cooling
pipes and one of them we found was
leaking and we found why it was leaking
and it was leaking because of a
phenomena called stress corrosion we
found some uh residual of hydrochloric
acid and this thing happen unfortunately
and as we found that we decided that we
wanted to fix and replace all of the
pipes because we found one leak and the
reason for this is that we didn't want
these pipes to leak Maybe 10 years from
now and we wanted to the machine to
operate for decades to come so taking
this very seriously but it will take us
another year uh to replace all these
cooling pipes but we will then move on
so we are also in the process now of
preparing a new Baseline a new Baseline
means new plan with a new cost estimate
new planning and uh uh so I'm not able
now to tell you when we will get you
know our next Milestones because I will
have have to explain this in the middle
of next year to uh the governance of
ether So-Cal ether Council but this is
the big job that we are doing now uh one
minute I would like to spend on how uh
ether and is contributing to the world
Fusion research program I mean Fusion is
an innovation program it's not just one
project one project uh can sustain much
of the answers or the the questions that
are brought forward but we need and I
think I welcome very much the fact that
we see now a renissance of fusion around
the world a lot of private investment
interest a lot of companies a lot of
opportunities for young people like you
to work in nuclear fusion not just in
iter but in other instances and I think
this is very much very much appreciated
because a lot of new ideas will come up
and I believe that ether can provide
some Support also that's why we are
explaining also things that go wrong
because I think Others May learn from
what we are doing it's part of our job I
believe uh we will provide certainly a
support to all the private Investments
and the firms very much welcome around
the world I mention here a few but there
are literally now uh almost 100 around
the world small investment and larger
investment companies that are addressing
the problem of nuclear fusion in a
different scale in different Niche so
with this I conclude my presentation in
I hope perfect okay perfect thank you
Petro so thanks a
[Applause]
lot so as I mentioned uh we keep the
questions for the end and I would like
to underline something that Peter just
said that it's great to see so many
young faces here uh and this is really
the future and we need you so we need
you to get excited about this because
this is you know it's your future it's
nice to to see that there are many young
young possibly scientists here or
Engineers okay we go now to our next uh
our next speaker um masiah
hanada uh yes from uh he's director
general of Naka Fusion Institute in
Japan okay first of all I like to say
I'm very much honored uh invite to be
invited by this meeting so I greatly
appreciate you know uh Italian Embassy
thank you very much so uh in in Japan
Tokamak plasma is developed in know qst
National Institute for qu Quantum uh
Science and Technology we have you know
two Institute one is know Naka site and
the other is loc site so we have a
totally 600 sta uh uh
employed
green okay so here we have you know the
development you know uh stage for Fusion
energies we use the you know stage
approach we started know uh you know
Fusion Energy since
1985 so here you can middle side you can
see we are here so we use the you know
ITA project and also broad approach
activities which is also International
collaborations so we use using
using you know two you know uh uh pass
uh we realize you know the demo reactor
in the middle of these
centuries here Japanese Fusion Energy
Innovation strategies in this April
Japanese government formulates you know
the Japanese Fusion Energy Innovation
strategies so Japan will not miss you
know the opportunity to enter the Bing
global fusion supply chain competitions
so for development of fusion industry
matching of the companies by establish
of fusion Industry Council of Japan
aiming at the fion physical year to
23 so second Japan will accelate in the
realization of the Fusion Energy for
Fusion Energy Technologies acceleration
of the R and D anticipating the future
development of the demo through the in
ITA and Broad approach
Japan will establish the in Fusion
industry councils strengthen its support
to emerging Technologies develop
educational programs so for framework to
promote a Fusion Energy Innovation
strategies establishment of the fusion
Technology Innovation Hub and also
Fusion uh energy education program will
be
provided here you can see the UN Fusion
Technology Innovation Hub this is for to
open Innovation for the developing
Fusion
Industries second objective is uh to
accelerate the demo development
fostering young leaders who are able to
take in initiative in the ITA and jt60
research and in the
overall uh integration of fusion plant
towards a demo so in both NAA and Cas
Institute existing facilities are opened
to Fusion development to be done by
Industries we have already opened the in
website to push the in company to
participate in the fusion development
some of the Japanese companies are
interested and asked to
qst so uh here you can see in Fusion
startup all
also startups from the fusion
development from the Viewpoint of the
know uh industrial you know application
of the fusion technology some of the
fusion technology are to be
commercialized the Define defining
technology of the Barum and rum that are
used in the blanket is applied to the
the product reum and Barum that are
widely used in the market startup
companies are newly established as qst
Ventures so we have you know two you
know the startup
companies meso and listy so meso
provides in the low energy consumption
process of the in Barum with alar and RF
power uh this also can be applied to the
you the recycling of the lare metal this
T provides in a very simple process on
lithium with the lithium ionic
conductors
so I change you know little bit to
change you know my topics I will show
the you know the fusion development of
the Tokamak Plasma in J in qsd yeah you
we started the development of
1985 uh since that we optimize the you
know the shape of the the plasma and
also optimize the you know magnetic
field we achieve know a very great uh
record
for example know ion temperature is you
know 5.2 billion uh not 100 million
degrees which is a Guinness record
unfortunately the obtained data is
almost less than 100 uh second so
therefore uh
we decided to to to extend the Know bar
par
durations uh one of the you know uh key
issue is is you know heat Road
of confinement magnet so therefore we
use know super conducting magnet that is
almost no no
resistivity so here you can see you know
the jt60 right side so this is the
largest super conducting toak device
before the eer so we have in three
objectives one is you know the
supportive research for eer second is a
complimentary research for demo so s is
a forer next Generations to realize you
know the demo in the uh in uh in the
middle of this
centuries oh here you can see you know
the center side this is you know the
jt60 essay very much you know the
complicated but you know this is actual
you know pictures
so we started you know the assembly uh
since you know the 13
uh
2013 then the you know March
2020 uh compression of the gt60 s
Construction so November 2020 coil is
super uh coil is in super contacting
state right side you can see you know
the uh leg coil voltage equivalent to
the you know the register of the coil uh
steeply decrease to zero so March 2021
Integrity commissioning suspended due to
the incident as a terminal joint with
are insufficient voltage insura uh
capabilities we suspended in the uh
experim uh integrated commissioning
after that this year may so weart
integrated
commissioning so after the you know the
careful reinforcement of the insulation
capability in over 100
locations so then you know
July coils again super contacting state
so very recently October we succeeded in
the first plasma of the j60 ESS so this
is you know the big milestone to proceed
pro pro proceed you know the our you
know
experiment I I'm very much happy to
inform this good news to you we are
too so thank you that's all but you know
one one say I have a time yes yes have
two so our you know the collaboration
broader approach and jt60 Essay is a
broad approach but you know strongly
related with you know it once we have
find know some you know incident or
something so this information is you
know shared with you know it so it
too not to same things okay so right now
we are in know the good collaboration
then you know the ITA and gt60 sa both
of this machines you know the realiz you
know the next toak device that's all
thank you very much thank
you thank you very much uh masiah I just
want to point out that we this is a
second example you see when something
happens a little incident these are such
complex structures such big structures
that they stop for two years I mean and
uh this is just normal so these are
things that take time it's just so that
the public understands how complicated
they are let's now go to the third
speaker step cowy director of Princeton
plasma physics lab from the
US so um I'm delightful to be here and
with my colleagues in in in fusion um
I'm going to talk a little bit about the
strategy that the US has to get to
Fusion electricity because the mo I I
give a lot of public talks about fusion
and at the end of every talk somebody
asked me okay so when are we going to
have Fusion electricity right and
usually I look
embarrassed um um because in fact we've
got a lot of innovation that's needed to
get to Fusion
electricity and up until recently
governments uh the US government has had
a strategy that we'll we'll do the
science of fusion we'll figure out all
the things about Fusion but we'll have
no strategy for delivering
electricity but two things have changed
that and and this uh last year we had a
sea change in the US government's
approach to to fusion um and we had I'll
get to the two things in a moment I
haven't forgotten them yeah um uh we had
a a summit event in the in the White
House and prior to that Summit um
members of the office of Science and
Technology policy from from the White
House and members of the Department of
energy came to Princeton to discuss how
fast could we get
Fusion how quickly could we get to some
electricity from Fusion we had had a
National Academy report that
said that in the um by the end of the
2030s or the beginning of the 2040s the
US should have an ambition
to get some electricity from Fusion this
was a report that completely changed the
tone of the discussion up to that point
we had said well we want to do some
fusion but we'll do it as a scientific
experiment not as a preliminary to a
commercial object and this Summit in the
White House on March 2020 I'm the guy
with without the blue hair um in the
middle there um and on the right is
actually the Secretary of Energy is uh
in the in the green right in the middle
of that and and and these are the people
um very much in charge of this area of
Science in the United States um and they
were all there and Congressional
Congress people were there and this was
to launch this bold decadal strategy for
fusion um it said that the department of
energy in the private sector should
produce net electricity in a fusion
plant in the United States in the 2035
2040 time
frame
now this is a stretch goal because we
haven't done everything in in in fusion
and in fact the eer experiment is going
to be the most critical scientific step
in getting to Fusion we need to actually
demonstrate that you can have a self-
sustained Fusion burn that's where
Fusion is making heat and that heat is
sustaining the plasma at a temperature
like 20 150 200 million degrees and you
can do that in a sustained way for some
time until we've done that we don't
actually have the scientific
demonstration that we have Fusion but
what
this uh government initiative said is we
should be developing everything else
simultaneously so when we get this
Fusion burn we're ready to kind of start
the process of making some electricity
from it immediately so why the hurry I
mean it's a good question you know after
all these years of of working on Fusion
why are we in a hurry to do this well I
think the first is that energy analysis
of the US Energy needs if we want to get
to zero carbon in the United
States The Missing Link is really what
we call firm energy sources ones that
you can turn on and turn off when you
need them so when the sun doesn't shine
and we don't have solar and when the
wind doesn't blow and we don't have wind
right we can turn on these firm energy
plants and deliver from that and the
options for that are very very
few and we need some more options in
that space if we're going to decarbonize
the American grd so the first reason for
this change of of strategy is the need
we really do need Fusion we don't just
it would it's not just nice to have but
by the middle of this Century we need
Fusion the second is that there have
been
demonstrations that make us believe that
Fusion is possible and the the first of
This was um in in Princeton in
1994 we demonstrated that that the
green the blip on the right hand side
it's time along the bottom its fusion
power up the side this machine that you
can see in this picture took the
temperature of a mixture of dyum and TR
up to about 250 million de and for 1
second we got 10 million watts of fusion
power this this historic experiment um
and it would put put Fusion really on
the map it said we could get the
conditions for
fusion um not self- sustained Fusion but
we could get the conditions for fusion
and so we could actually create those
conditions that you need in a future
Fusion reactor that record was broken by
The Joint European tourus which is just
south of Oxford in England and it's the
European machine that um was actually a
little more powerful than the American
machine and that they got up to 16
million Watts that's the blue line and
that was a a marvelous achievement but
one other thing is if you look at that
blue line right at the end it just
collapses right um there were that was
not what you would call a nicely
sustained uh conditions for Fusion the
at that time the best really sustained
conditions was the red line which is 4.5
million watts of fusion power sustained
throughout the time that we could
sustain the plasma the duum and tritium
the Fusion fuel through that time and
that was an amazing um achievement at
that time and I think it really made us
confident that if we go forward to eer
we would actually get Fusion uh
sustained Fusion burnout of eer and this
was um just the um December the 21st
2021 recently jet broke its own
record um here they sustained
essentially 10 million watts of fusion
PA for 5 seconds uh that's as long as
they could do it in that that experiment
and and it it was a real a real
confirmation that we can get the
conditions of fusion and this is
scientifically possible so the second
reason that there's confidence and
people are saying we should accelerate
towards electricity and fusion is that
we know we can do it we don't know that
we can sustain a fusion burn but we know
we can get the conditions so there's
some optimism that we can really get
there um at that time so I see those as
the two factors and then another real
shot in the arm for the American uh
Fusion program is there's another way to
do fusion and that is to make a tiny
little
pellet explode with fusion power by
compressing it with lasers you take the
world's most powerful laser which
delivers two megga of laser light I
always think of a megga is about the
energy of a hang
grenade or a candy bar um hand grenades
release their energy faster um and it
you take these two megga of laser light
and you focus it down onto this object
and you squeeze the Fusion fuel down and
you create uh Fusion conditions for a
nanc and it explodes with fusion power
and in in this case on De December the
5th
2022 it gave more fusion power than we
were putting in and that's the first
time in any experiment that we actually
got um into that condition where we get
actually a fusion burn in the middle of
this now this may be a harder way
actually to make fusion electricity but
it gives us some confidence it may or
may not be actually but it gives us some
confidence that we can sort of push this
forward the other big driver in the
United States is is that there's a huge
investment in in Venture Capital
infusion startup companies five to six
billion dollars in investment in the
last five years that's phenomenal
amounts in a technology that is really
at a very
low minutes I was going to say if
there's eight minutes left I'm really
doing well um give me eight more minutes
um f and one of those uh companies uh
spin out of MIT that's basically trying
to do a high field version of ITA High
magnetic field version of ITA has raised
actually $2.2 billion dollar in venture
capital investment from people like Bill
Gates and George Saros and I I I quit
these days that if you're a high net
worth individual you have to have a
space company and a fusion company so um
this is this is energizing the field in
a in a big way and some of these
companies frankly are Bonkers they their
technology will never work and some of
them are doing really really interesting
things and I think we can see an an
acceleration in all the things that uh
will drive us towards Fusion electricity
over this time
um I want to emphasize something that
perhaps doesn't get emphasized enough
because over the last 20 years we began
to have computational models of what
goes on inside a fusion experiment that
actually agree with with experiment when
I got into the field they didn't it was
kind of empiricism you drew lines you
plotted graphs and you said that roughly
follows this line now we have these um
beautiful computational models and they
they run on the biggest computers in the
world and they're able to they're able
to calculate what would happen in a
fusion device if we changed this if we
changed that so we can start to do
innovation in a virtual space and space
of computer simulations and what we've
done at Princeton is we've began to sort
of systematize this using artificial
intelligence and the and the world's
biggest computers and these models and
looking for the optimum configurations
and starting to look at new accelarated
configurations these are these wonderful
Twisted magnetic field configurations
and some of our young people there on
the top right is Elizabeth Paul who's
just become a professor at Columbia
University Matt andman uh Felix parah
who's our head of theory at at Princeton
um this guy on the left is eggy Coleman
um no Mandel in the middle and Adell
Wright on the bottom she's just gone as
a professor to Wisconsin they're
starting to say what would be the
optimum configuration in the computer
could we build that could we make a a
better a better bottle for our Fusion
device I think there's some really
fantastic things going on in this space
and there at least three of the spin out
companies are going along the line of
taking these configurations and trying
to make them and see if they will make a
better Fusion device I think delivering
electricity by
2035 is a bit of a stretch to be honest
but it's a good goal to say we're not
just doing Fusion for science but we're
doing Fusion because we want to make
some electricity thank you very
[Applause]
much thank you Steve
I mean we start seeing a a pattern I
mean both almost all the three of you
talked about this uh surge of also the
the private Industries coming in and
this cross fertilization also that you
that you mentioned this is something
that is seems to be accelerated now so
um yeah we'll talk about this more later
let's now go to our next speaker P
sonato who is the president of rfx
Consortium in Padova
Italy thank you uh thank you very much
for having invited me for this uh panel
and with this colleague in my
contribution today I want to witness
what is the role of the Italian research
and Industrial environment is working
for for Fusion also because uh I think
that in as would like to demonstrate and
convince you that H we are in actually
in Italy in a situation in which the
from from the scientific point of view
technological development in the
research institution and technological
transfer and involvement on the
industries we are in a situation today
that is
unprecedented uh in the history of the
research on Fusion in in in
Italy uh we you see here in the
background uh the uh CNR the National
Council research site in padwa in which
we host three of the four uh okay uh
there is some
noise okay okay probably it's better now
uh in which we OST three of of the main
uh four facilities that are uh working
or they are in under construction
development in in Italy we seen the map
or the uh cities in which we have uh
research
institution that are working in uh on on
Fusion
research uh now I start to introduce you
uh the four main uh facilities in which
we are working in in Italy uh the first
one is okay we have already understood
from our colleagues and from the video
that the main line mainst streamline for
the development of fusion is on Tokamak
andar I think that will speak something
more about about this but in padwa we
are developing a different concept a
concept in that in which if for the
stator we have in the our toroidal
plasma no plasma current and all the
magnetic field is generated by external
coils in the center in the Tokamak we
have a large thidal plasma current as we
have understood this morning and we have
a larg thidal field produced by
external uh huge uh
windings in the rever F pinch this uh
um in this in this uh line on on the
right side uh we have large
thidal current large poloidal current
and therefore most of the magnetic field
necessary for the confinement of the
plasma is generated by the plasma itself
from the external coils we need only to
generate some fields to control the
surface of the plasma and by controlling
the symmetry of the plasma column in the
center of the plasma there is a core
that is very hot it has an helical shape
similar to the helical shape that we
have we experienced in the accelerator
in a completely different confinement
from the physics point of view this is
something that is very interesting
and uh this uh development has been done
in rfx that is this toal experiment in
Padua the most important results have
been obtained in the last uh decade and
uh now this experiment that is one of
this
um Italian infrastructure that is at
high priority in the energet in in the
en
sector now is under
upgrade to try to uh
explore uh new uh performances and
better performances than uh than before
this historically is the first uh
important device that is still under
operation
today the and the second one is
something that has been mentioned by
Petro few minutes ago uh the new neutral
Bean test facility in padwa we have the
only part of The Ether that has been
built and has been decided after the
decision to build eer has been decided
to
also establish a facility for the
development of one of the main eating
system of eer the neutral beam test uh
facility this the neutral Bean test
facility that is osted in the premise of
of padwa of the
CNR the in has been or is under
development with a CO strong cooperation
with uh three of the partner of iter
Japan that supplied uh the one megga
volt power supply India and Europe
through the to the fusion for energy
agency and with Fusion therefore with
all the European laboratory that are
working on on the development of fusion
in Europe and uh within this uh facility
that you know for one side replicate
exactly the neutral beam that will be
installed later and uh reproduced into
uh system in in kadash uh we have two
facilities one is spider spider is a
source of plasma to generate negative
ion of hydrogen it is easy to remove one
electron from hydrogen hydrogen Al only
one electron but it is difficult to
attach a second electron to the uh to
the hydrogen species uh we need to do
this because when we accelerate at one
megga volt one negative ion of hydrogen
it is still possible to remove this
electron if if it is a positive ion it
is not possible to
reattach the electron and therefore the
beam needs to be neutral to be in in
injected inside uh the plasma spider is
devoted to this experiment is in
operation uh has operated three years
and a half and now is on the final uh re
installation after a significant
refurbishment of the source Mya is the
full power and full energy injector that
is under development in uh
for
forer uh this injector we can uh please
if you can launch the uh the the video
uh in a radio frequency S Plasma Source
we generate ions and we generate
radicals these ions of hydrogen will be
converted in negative ions and then they
will be extracted by an electrostatic
field that will accelerate the beam uh
uh and will extract the 1 megga volt
beam we have
1,280 beamlet uh that uh produce
negative ions then after the generation
of this beam the beam must be
neutralized and only after the
neutralization we can inject inside the
uh
plasma now we here we see the source of
spider and on the bottom left we see not
the movie of the beamlet that are
accelerated but the real uh video or the
real camera picture of the beamlet that
are extracted and accelerated in the
bottom left on the right side you can
see and observe some relevant components
of uh me IA the vacuum vessel the
transmission line we have in the
transmission line one mega Volt of
voltage between the inner conductor and
the blue body that you see on the top
right side with the flag of Japan that
has built this uh power supply and this
transmission line you see also the inner
of the of the transmission line where in
the internal the in the conductor in the
middle here we have one mega Volt on the
surrounding uh vessel surface we have
zero volt one mega Volt in less than one
meter it is something that is is
incredible in in insulated gas and
another uh component the fourth facility
under construction in Italy is the
verter test Tokamak is a unique facility
in which uh we are uh in which we want
want to develop the system that uh has
to handle the power and the particle
that the reactor will produce that must
be extracted from the plasma this is a
device that is under construction in
frascati in the Ana site in which
collaborate a number of institution that
is also part of the institution the
Consortium rfx and also from aerofusion
but the last part that I wanted to
mention to you is that all these
activity in for the construction the
installation the integration and the
commission and operation of the facility
in in Italy and the collaboration that
the research institution with Europe and
worldwide have have also uh produced a
transfer technology to the industries
and I show here only the uh uh the
relevant cooperation for iter you see
that vacuum vessel half of the vacuum
vessel more or less is built by Italian
industry top uh right side half of the
toroidal coils are produced in Italy
also close to to to to pad close to
Venice the component mechanical and it
fles component are produced also uh in
Italy and also the super conducting coil
and uh to Super conducting strengths
within the coil is the technology
developed in Italy but not only here
here I show only super conductive and
mechanical but also on power on power
supply system in control system in
Diagnostics and in integration the
Italian companies there are as I
mentioned before tens of company that
have collaborated or are collaborating
with the research institution and the
technology transfer is very relevant in
the Italian environment thank you very
much I'm sorry if I be a little bit long
but really nice to see also that Italy
is at the top of this technology with
together with many many other partners
okay we move on to now hartmut zom and
hartmut he's not only you know the
direct of the max PL Institute for
plasma physics but he's also a very
famous and I see some of you smiling a
very famous TV star because he's running
this YouTube channel and he say he has
300,000 followers in this YouTube
channel so go ahead please haret thank
[Applause]
you okay so we are a bit late and I was
told to keep it simple so that's what I
tried to do you have 10 minutes relax I
have only four slides and they don't
have a lot of text but we should be
great to go so the first thing and it
has been mentioned quite a bit I want to
point out is the aspect of international
collaboration Petro said that one of the
seven partners of iter is Europe but in
fact Europe is not one country so I
think it's a major achievement in the
European Fusion program to get our act
together and to be organized across all
of Europe and we do this in a so-called
Consortium so we are five financed co-
financed by the European commission and
we are co-financed as a Consortium out
of 29 countries which has 31 research
institutions and you read yourself a lot
of people involved universities we have
access via the universities to students
at very high level and all in all there
about 4,000 persons working in this and
the way this is done in this Consortium
is that we get our act together
literally by preparing a proposal to the
European commission how we want to do
the research on Fusion which brings us
forward in an organized way and we bring
this to the European commission and we
are financed as a whole and then we
distribute within this Consortium so you
can see all the European Union countries
in their you see on top Switzerland and
the UK who are not part of the European
Union but they have or had access to the
urum program over which we are financed
and we actually have a very good
collaboration with them as well so
Switzerland is more or less still a
partner in there the UK you all know is
even no longer Europe in some sense but
we still work together with them very
well and so you can see this and the way
this works is that if we have a physics
challenge like ITA comes and says we
want to know XYZ how does the plasma
operate with
this they ask actually Euro Fusion and
the EUR Fusion Consortium says let's
discuss which of the machines or which
of the Laboratories the yellow dots in
this is best suited to do this and then
it is transferred to these and we work
all together on this problem on the one
machine which might be the best suited
or even two or three machines these are
toomax and celerator and we could figure
out things much better if it was just
one partner who was paid or say being
tusked to do this so I think this is a
great achievement within Europe we're
very proud of this and I think it also
works quite well we do have a road map
to Fusion electricity like the one that
Steve was discussing you note we don't
have numbers in terms of years here so
you can ask me later about it but what
you see is on the upper branch of this
these are all the experiments the
experimental devices which we are using
in order to understand how to make the
plasma hot how to do these 250 million
degree plasma and how to keep it burning
or say in this state for a long time
which used to be seconds only as you saw
which is now tens of seconds as we have
seen in the Japanese TOA could be up to
hundreds of seconds and then this is the
culmination of this will be ether where
we can really produce power with it on
the lower leg of this the blue arrow you
see all the technology it was already
mentioned the more you go into doing
this towards commercial Fusion where
things should not be done by physicists
who put tape around stuff in order to
fix it but who really want to build
something that you can run for a very
long time you have to do all this
engineering here and so there is all
this engineering it doesn't really
matter what the individual dots show but
it's very important that these things so
the plasma physics via ITA the
technology via ITA but also this
dedicated Technology Program go into
something we call Demo which is a
demonstration fusion power plant and you
can see the aspect in this version of
the road map already that Steve has
mentioned mentioned it is a
parallelization if you are in publicly
financed research environment usually
you don't go in parallel you don't say
let's try this let's try this let's try
that and only one of them will work or
maybe none of them so we waste the
taxpayers money in some sense if you
have more partners and private money
flowing into the program which is the
case now you can actually go in parallel
and say there is more risk appetite in
industry and they can fail and failure
is part on the way look just look at
what space X how many rocket space X
exploded before the first one took off
so this is something we anticipate so
the demonstration fusion power plant is
actually running in parallel taking all
the information from the experiment from
The Ether in the end which is very
important in terms of the plasma physics
demonstration and also the technology
and leading into the fusion power plant
which you see on the right side now
there is another thing which is special
about Europe you see there are two power
plants which means we we haven't made up
our mind if you like there is one the
upper one which is the tokomak that
everybody was talking about and the
lower one is what we call disc celerator
and which you have seen in several
instances in the video and others as
well so Euro Fusion says let's go for a
toak demo but let's also strengthen the
path on the accelerator research and
maybe the accelerator in the end is the
better power plant if you go to this and
I'm also saying this because in Germany
we think the stator is great now I'm
coming to the German part of the program
and so whoops
I'm and this machine you have seen quite
a bit in the slides now it's called
wendelstein CX w7x it's a stellarator I
come back to this in a moment it is run
in Germany it's the world largest stator
and it has been commissioned in 2016 and
is now running for six seven years and
produces very nice results it's the
largest machine of its kind it has
broken many records world records for
the stator and yet we are increasing
this and and sort of doing more
experiments so what you see in the
middle is a computer animation you see
the plasma is this yellow thing which
winds around if you follow the green
line very well you will see that it
winds around such as has been described
for the too Mar itself but this is done
by Twisted coils which are all on the
outside of the vessel so there is no
current
in the plasma different from the tokomak
which means this machine is
intrinsically steady state so you turn
on the magnetic field superc conducting
coils by the way on w7x and then you can
run it for as long as you like and as
much as physicists like self
organization P gorio I think for an
engineer self organization is terrible
because the plasma might go where it
wants so we really want to go for sort
of the thing which is most bound to the
external control of the magnetic field
so as I said this machine is run in
Germany near the Baltic Sea in gal and
you see some pictures of the assembly
here it's a huge Beast actually it took
a very long time to build this up so
it's 10
m it's 10 M from the left to the right
it is super conducting coils in there
and it went into operation very smoothly
so in fact there was not too much screw
up in this on the way we had our
problems as well and it's now running
very well actually and this brings me to
the last slide the last slide being what
does the German program look like the
German program as you can imagine the
direct funding for This research goes
into a few large centers because this is
big research I mean we have the w7x the
ventle Stein stator which is run in the
north so up there if you're familiar
with the German map K is up there where
the sign of Max blank Society is this is
gal and it's about 500 people working
there and so this is a large like a
nation lab which is run and mainly
financed by the government but it has to
be concentrated in this we have another
one Max branch of this Max PL Institute
where I'm working in ging near Munich so
there we have a machine which looks
prototypical of what what ether looks
like and we do a lot of research which
is directly related to the support of
eer and then there is the more
technology oriented research so there is
UL where you see the Vic J which is a
Institute of the hero assciation there
it's mainly studied plasma wall
interactions and materials which are
very important where I mean the plasma
somehow has to touch the wall and then
you have to get rid of the power which
goes there and there is the specific
Fusion technology which is done by
another helmo Association Institute
which is the kit cultu institute for
technology and to finish with um we also
see startups in Germany which is a great
thing because there is additional money
coming into the game so we have two
reason recently founded startups in
magnetic fusion gaus fusion and Proxima
Fusion no surprise they look at the
accelerator because they are located in
Germany so they find this very
interesting concept actually and there
are also in inertial Fusion I should say
startups what this has prompted is that
we also see more money in Germany being
put into Fusion so the government bmbf
bundas ministerium for building and
forun recently announced another 370
million Euros which go into Fusion for
the next 5 years and this to some degree
has been
prompted by the successes that Steve has
mentioned but also by the feeling that
now is the time to involve industry with
the slot ups for example and to build up
a fusion industry ecosystem which could
in the end deliver the Final Fusion
reactor for this because this the fusion
power plant itself will not be built by
research institutes this will be built
by industry and I think I more or less
kept my time stuff thank you thank
you wow you guys have been perfect thank
you so much and again thank you for
coming here I mean Steve comes from the
US masiah comes from
Japan Peter comes from France maybe or
wherever you were he worked he's already
always traveling around so um now uh we
leave uh you know this remaining time
for questions uh to you starting from
you um and please if you want to ask a
question wait for the microphone to come
uh since we are streaming this event so
let's start here and here's the
microphone that comes you can ask your
question to any of the speakers or a
specific speaker you go ahead whoever
you want thank you very much so first of
all thank you to the Italian Embassy to
assembling such an impressive panel I'm
very very glad uh to have the
opportunity to listen to you I was I was
really happy about what Steve mentioned
regarding the progresses in in
simulation because as I remember mhd
simulation belongs to the most nasty
things that uh you can do as a physicist
um can you expand a little bit on this
process especially with regard to the
question could it be possible that uh
when these simulations get more and more
accurate and Powerful to to tackle the
the challenge of the sheer size of these
machines I mean obviously we have some
scaling issues here but one of the most
pressing critique points regarding
Fusion activities for for plants is the
the investment size the shear size the
complexity so if there are sufficient
progress in in simulations would there
there be a possibility to build more
compact
machines so um sorry yes go ahead go
ahead Steve yes uh I mean this is this
is really really the motivation behind
the big simulation program which is try
and push down the costant scale of
fusion to make it more Market ready in
in in terms of its size um what
dominates most of our
devices is that the heat leaks through
the magnetic field through
turbulence tiny little swirls because
it's hot in the middle and it's cold at
the edge these tiny little swirls carry
hot stuff out and cold stuff in very
much like when you heat a pan of water
on the gas stove the bottom is hot and
it rises and the top is cold and it
falls and you get bubbling in in there
and what we've learned to do is to
minimize that turbulence but not get a
get get it out of there right there's
always some turbulence inside inside the
plasma and about 20 years ago we first
started simulating that turbulance with
some veracity because the plasma is very
thin so it doesn't really behave like a
fluid it behaves like a collection of
charged particles and those charged
particles are going around the the
magnetic field lines very very fast
compared to this turbulence and so they
behave like charged Rings because
they're going around almost in circles
and and we have something called gyro
kinetic simulation that 20 years ago was
very very basic but now there are codes
there's codes at Munich and there's
codes in at Princeton that actually can
simulate that
turbulence almost almost fast enough
that you could do it between a shot on
on the experiment um they still use very
big computers and you have to there's a
lot of mathematics that goes into it but
the um the the early career people are
really advancing this extraordinarily
fast and then integrating that with AI
tools or artificial intelligence tools
that'll allow you to take bigger steps
in your calculation ations what we've
actually done is what my last slide was
about was actually have a sort of
optimization routine looking for better
and better configurations that have less
and less turbulent transport inside them
we can actually go through a loop and
iterate and then if that configuration
isn't quite good enough we tweak it and
we go to another one and we go to
another one that wasn't possible three
years ago and actually the German
accelerator was design designed in a
very similar way but before we could
calculate the turbulence and so now by
integrating the turbulence we've got
real veracity and to the model of the
plasma that I think we can really use to
to drive down the cost and scale
Fusion thank you thank you very much I
think there's another question first
here and then there yes please hello
good morning my name is y m um I was
running the hmods association as
president for 10 years and was in charge
somehow also for uh nuclear energy and
nuclear fusion uh first of all let me
thank the Italian Embassy again for
being part of the Berlin science week
and bringing together here to Berlin
such a a panel welcome to berin by the
way so when I was a young student and I
had to give a seminar talk on nuclear
fusion the message was nuclear fusion
will be
35 40 years ahead you know this is the
so-called Fusion constant when you when
you talk to people today it's always you
know uh not tomorrow it's U some decades
ahead so maybe you can say a few words
also on realistic time scales to get
Fusion for electricity I think this was
a very important remark by you Steve
because Fusion for science is one thing
but Fusion for electricity is completely
different it's a completely different I
would say also mental
setting and I guess many of you have
seen this movie Oppenheimer you know
there was a need for urgency to come up
with something really
big maybe there is more urgency now also
for
Fusion but I mean let's be realistic you
you said that too
is this urgency really in the heads of
all those who not only working on it but
have to supported politics and also uh
Society so final
remark what about Russia China Korea
South Korea how are they doing in this
worldwide competition maybe we should
also get a few of the insights that you
have how I mean the competitor
you know outside the Western Hemisphere
doing yeah maybe this could be something
that you could comment on to start with
and maybe others could add Petro please
start yes so so your last question
presumably yeah that was a question yes
my observation is that first of all
Russia and Korea and South Korea are
collaborating in the eer um framework at
making eer really their centerpiece
particularly for Russia because there is
really no other big research
infrastructure in the Russian Federation
for what concerns Fusion although the
name Tokamak comes from researchers is
in Russia they really made iter as the
centerpiece and in Korea they have a
research infrastructure called Kar which
is a relatively small size super
conducting Tokamak but they are in
essence strongly counting on The Ether
project in China uh there has been in my
observation an impressive acceleration
in Fusion research in the last couple of
decades and what I could see recently is
something which is really impressive so
they are investing a lot in developing
Technologies they are supporting The
Ether project very strongly very
strongly I must say uh but at the same
time they are developing a parallel
research infrastructure which are say
quite large so as um my colleague masiah
JT 6sa now it's the biggest Tokamak in
the world um that just started operating
my expectation is that we will see uh
burning plasma experiments being
developed also in
China so that is I think quite
encouraging uh the if I may
spend words about many questions on this
uh about Fusion I myself when I started
working I asked the question to my boss
and my boss told me you will operate the
demo and evidently this is not going to
happen and so but maybe somebody in this
room will uh maybe maybe maybe but I
won't tell them I won't tell them that
so uh I think I totally agree on the
fact that modeling will be Central to
the development of fusion because we
know that Fusion is possible we know
that and we also know that we can get
more energy out than the one we put in
we know that physically this has been
demonstrated we don't know yet if we can
sustain this process for time constants
which are say in the minutes minutes or
hours
scale from a few seconds to minutes and
hours there's a big difference because
the time constants of structures is
changing and everything is driven by
something which is called Power density
Fusion is something which is specific it
needs to operate at 150 million degrees
this means uh and sorry I think like an
engineer because I am one you cannot
really exhaust the power by embedding a
matrix of coolant inside you have to get
the power out in order to run say uh
steam in a
turbine and you cannot really do this
infusion other than on the surface you
can do this with fire you can embed the
fire in in a in a heat sink you can do
this with fishion you can embed the the
the say the fuel cells in the in the
water but you cannot do this with Fusion
you have to get the power on a surface
and you need the big Fireball because as
uh as we know we cannot sort of get the
condition on small scale a lot of it is
driven by power density so I believe
that personally that the development in
modeling will not so much reduce the
size I don't think so because size will
not make it
economical uh we need hundreds of
megawatts we spoke about megajoule
before and megajoule as Steve said is a
candy bar we have in iter we will go in
terms of compare with jets each pulse
will generate 10,000 to 100,000 more uh
in terms of energy it's a huge step so
this is what is in facing us we have now
that now that we know that we can get
more energy out than the one we put in
the question will be can we do this for
minutes and hours that will be the scope
of ether and then the question will be
can we get more money out of the money
we put in this is a key question because
for an energy source to be on the grid
it's one thing to put it on the grid
just for sake of it it's another thing
to make it to put it on the grid so that
you deal ities will bite and for that I
think essentially the computer modeling
will allow to reduce
complexity cost is not just driven by
size cost is driven by complexity and I
believe that a lot of the complexity
that you see in ether that we have to
face in ether will gradually get much
much simpler by finding better magnetic
configuration and being able to optimize
the structure in a way that will make it
much cheaper to build thank you thank
you uh very much Petro I see that harmut
wants to add something here yes I would
like to address the fusion constant
because that's really one of my
favorites I was actually surprised it
was only the second question usually
it's the first one so
so first of all I think when I heard it
the first time it was 50 years and then
it was 30 years and I think now we are
saying 20 years but you can say always
say 20 years I think this is the first
time in in my career that I see a sense
of urgency coming on for Fusion which we
haven't had before
so in Germany where there was usually we
were always doing basic research in
Fusion now there is this Push by the
bmbf I think this is also because we see
the chance to parallelize as I said
before the sense of urgency comes from
several it's I think it's a bit
embarrassing I found in Germany there
was more sense of urgency when people
were told that they couldn't Heat their
houses in the winter then when climate
change was always on the plate but for
whatever reason I think there is a sense
of urgency and this is a chance so what
we put forward as an estimate was what
we call the 2020 strategy which is 20
years 20 billion euros and I think this
is more or less consistent with what the
other partners have said but it's very
important you get the 20 billion EUR at
least on the horizon to do this because
just saying we' go faster without having
the measure to do is very difficult and
the second thing you have to accept that
we can go in parallel we can go down a
path which might fail we have to use the
large increase in money to parallelize
and to do things which might fail at
some point and I agree with Steve some
of the things we see of the private
companies look very challenging if
you're generous and maybe they will
never work but on the other hand we will
learn from all of these and doing this
in parallel is a luxury which we haven't
had in the program you know yourself how
long we took to say we can do the next
step because we have shown to 99% we are
sure so I think now is the time and I'm
just hoping we can Channel this in a
Direction Where We really go faster and
then maybe at some point it goes to 10
and then to zero years who knows thank
you harmut yes uh Steve wants to add
something I just wanted please use the
microphone I just want to make um is
this on yeah yeah okay sorry
there are young people in the
audience and I do think that sometimes
we think my generation thinks we've had
all the ideas and now we need to just
work them out there's probably some
really smart things that we don't know
yet and that another generation of
scientists and Engineers coming into
Fusion will discover um so don't listen
to people like
me think for yourself self Fusion needs
many more ideas and and I think the
challenge is not doing Fusion it's doing
Fusion at a cost the consumer wants to
pay for their electricity and if we can
do that we'll never not know how to do
Fusion y thank you thank you Steve so I
would like to now give the microphone to
uh yes the the the lady in red you hello
everybody I'm Marta I'm from University
of Oxford and I worked at ta
Technologies and what I was very well
maybe not shocked by but s by is that
Marvel Fusion decided to leave Germany
and invest in the US and I was
researching the landscape of various
European countries and seeing that a lot
of them are still focused on ether but
with all the confusing uh and
controversial timelines and M
mismanagement and certain logistical
issues I think the EU should focus AIT
more on uh supporting the private
network of various Fusion companies like
the UK does and what I would find
interesting with regards to that is I've
been looking at Fusion legislation and I
know that the EU is I see that there is
an uh well sort of like star that people
are becoming U more interested in Fusion
but there is still you know no
legislation on the table perhaps but I
would be interested to know how do you
think Fusion should be legislated should
there be legislation that is Fusion
specific that I see that a lot of it is
eer focused uh I wouldn't want to see
something that's just a copy paste of
nuclear fision legislation and I don't
think it should be the same legislation
that would be for Renewables so where do
we find this Niche for Fusion
legislation and all of that okay so who
wants to take this there you go this is
a tough
one well F first of all the company
Marvel Fusion didn't leave Germany they
have a project where in the US a lab
Colorado Boulder University is paid and
they do experiments them I think that
they are still here in Germany so this
is was maybe bit exaggerated in the
Press but this is not I think the real
answer so the real question you want to
have answered is about the
legislation yes so eer was the
regulation of iter went under the French
Law And since there was nothing
comparable it went via fishion so this
is a the first thing to do would be to
say we have something which is strict
which is about fishion power plants and
we will go and see if we can make life
easier because Fusion doesn't have the
same risk of accidents doesn't have the
same class of high level waste which
takes very long time and what we see now
in the US and the UK is furthest
Advanced already is that they do it the
other way around they come from what
they call legislation for accelerators
so it is a source of radiation and it
has a nuclear aspect for sure but it is
very different from fishing and so the
present strategy is in the US and the UK
and also Japan to start from this and
say this is very different because we
have different accident scenarios which
are not by large and also waste which is
by large different from what is being
has in fact already been seen in fishion
and let's built up from this and we are
trying to make this work in Europe as
well now Continental Europe because the
UK already went ahead and say we should
do the same thing same thing we should
start with something actually like w7x
and astics upgrade our German
experiments are regulated they are
regulated under a very different for
then they are a fishing power plant and
we should keep this and we should start
and then say let's see what we have and
we will have to add stuff because it
produces so much more radioactivity but
it is is not like a fishing power plant
and I think you see a push everywhere I
mean each each of the companies has in
big letters on their website we need a
legislation we need rules and we need
them now and this is also a very
important aspect I just come back last
week from Boston from CFS this startup
visited them they actually say we need
the safety they no sorry the security to
know that if we start now building a
power plant we can also operate it and
they actually said we're willing to go
to the UK If the US doesn't come and say
we will have our rules and the UK has
rules so it's clear that if you want to
go fast you need these rules and so
there is a big push for this also in
Germany if you read the bmbf B for the
strategy it's already featured in
there thank you very much hartmut so
let's see are there other questions Sor
there's one sorry yes P go ahead add
something related to the regulation
it it it is clear that when we want to
build in our house an electrical plant
or we want to use any Appliance or
apparatus these must follow some rules
rules and regulation that are
established by uh regulatory
bodies but the all the uh path or the
trajectory to arrive to the regulation
is a quite long process that is develops
with the development of Technology ology
this is valid for any kind of technology
for electrical plant for pressure vessel
for any kind of our activities we we
need to follow regulations and rules
that are established by uh bodies that
are uh in charge to develop this type of
rules and
regulation Fusion cannot escape from
this has to follow the same and the time
to develop the regulation for which when
we are a able to produce electrical
energy we can switch on and uh and uh
inject Electric Power electric energy in
the network in the
grid what are the rules for the design
for the construction for the test for
the acceptance for the assembly for the
uh for the integration for the
commissioning before to be able to
switch on the power plant this is
something that is a process that in I am
a poor engineer like like pet
electrotechnical engineer but the all
these trajectory all this path is
something that tookes very long time to
be developed and might be step of test
and of verification before to adopt this
this is a process that we cannot skip
for any kind of type of Technology
development not only food
this is is clear now and eer for this
will play a very important role because
it's the first of kind of the of fusion
plant Fusion experiment that will
address
also part of most of the part of these
part of the process but there are others
the material another mentioned in rashio
the development of facility for
materials this is another aspect the
diver test talk in Italy will will
address another aspect then there is the
problem of the
fertilization production of trium from
lithium this is another aspect of it
developed but on top of that there are
the problem of definition of the
regulations and this is from the
engineering point of view is something
that cannot uh be developed in month or
small number of years is something that
require long time of Dev open for from
all the regulatory bodies yeah thank you
just maybe we have time for a last very
quick question a very quick answer come
on give him the
microphone can I ask can I ask a yes no
question yes go ahead so for
everybody was it harder to go to the
moon or is Fusion
harder so let's see not you know yes
question
either I think think evidently from my
stand point Sorry evidently it is harder
to get Fusion we have to on the other
hand think that getting because getting
on the moon was done in a different time
of course so it was very hard to do it
then I believe that in today's money
that project would cost 200 billion so
it is several times ether although
although ether is very expensive we
don't deny that it's a major investment
but it was done at a different time I
think they are all both equally if I may
say so it's neither yes or no they are
both equally tremendous Challenge from a
scientific standpoint I don't think that
it's Just Energy I think it's
also uh yes to achieve a new frontier
there are a lot of say spin-offs going
to to the moon at its own purpose so I
believe that there are similarities to
that but if I look forward certainly
from the standpoint of today's
technology it remains very easy to now
to go to the Moon it remains very very
complicated to achieve fusion and to
make it say
economical thank you thank you very much
I think unfortunately we have to close
uh this event here uh but I thank all of
you for uh attending and I would like to
again thank our five speakers thank you
so
much